well that's a good question I mean one
of the things they need to do is find we
do have a shortage I mean part of the
problems we've had a sort of long-term
devaluation of civil service in this
country so that I've been watching the
contrast between US Treasury and Her
Majesty's Treasury in Britain and US
Treasury is desperately trying to reach
recruit people from Wall Street because
it doesn't have your technical
competence and the British Treasury
doesn't seem to be that short of
competence but you know you can get them
and you know particularly have a new
administration coming in I bet they can
get a lot of smart people a lot of
people probably a lot of people will
have to be rotated in from Wall Street
there's a lot of people at the Fed at
the various feds of the New York Fed in
particular who know stuff so it's gonna
be tough but you know it doesn't have to
be perfect it just has to be something
that is not too bad and gets the money
flowing again that's the question was
the meaning of the word effective will
they spend it in a way that is better
than nothing
100 percent probability will it be spent
as well as ideally it should zero how
good will it be that remains to be seen
but I think people do understand some of
the principles and there's a pretty
there are at least a couple hundred
billion dollars of pretty good projects
out there to be started up quickly so a
good chunk of it I think will be spent
well the rest who knows
well probably not on us maybe I have
parked temporary basis but you know we
don't want I don't want to cease the
economy's commanding Heights and hold
them right I want I want to just have
money pumped in long enough to to get
the thing functioning and then reprieve
a-- ties you want to do what what sweden
did or you want to do what we did with
the s and LS when we had you know we had
to temporarily create an institution
that that took over a lot of their their
assets and and then disposed of them so
no it we probably do need yeah I mean
the tarp is kind of a new institution
right very haphazardly created but take
that thing and make it run right and get
you know get get some people get more
people recruited and preferably a few
people who are not from Goldman Sachs